Durchs Fenster fliegen
und dann weiterkämpfen?
7 Schläge auf den Kopf kassieren
und dann wieder aufstehen?
Mental Kräfte sammeln
und dann voll angreifen?
Ha!
In der Serie "Cobra Kai"
ist das kein Problem.
Aber geht das auch in echt?
Tach zusammen, Jack Pop hier.
"Cobra Kai never dies."
Deswegen geht die Serie
jetzt auch in die 5. Staffel.
Sie ist der Nachfolger
der "Karate Kid"-Filme.
Viele der Charaktere aus den 80ern
sind wieder mit dabei.
Genauso wie Karate an sich
und das berüchtigte Dojo "Cobra Kai".
What took you so long?
Die neue Staffel
ist der perfekte Anlass,
mal einen genaueren Blick
auf die Kampf-Szenen zu werfen.
Und zwar die außerhalb
der offiziellen Karate-Turniere.
Denn die sind die heftigsten.
Ich frage mich immer:
Wie zur Hölle halten die das aus?
Ist es realistisch, dass die
so doll einstecken können?
Das klären wir heute mit einem Arzt
vom St.-Georg-Klinikum in Leipzig.
Mit Dr. Jörg Böhme.
Dr. Böhme ist Chefarzt
für Unfallchirurgie.
Verletzungen durch Kampfsport und
Schlägereien sind Alltag bei ihm.
"Cobra Kai" hat er gemeinsam
mit seinem Sohn gesehen.
Für uns ist er also doppelt vom Fach.
Dr. Böhme, schön, dass Sie da sind.
- Ja, danke.
Wenn wir generell
auf Hollywood-Filme schauen:
Können Sie sich
Action-Filme angucken,
ohne zu denken,
wie soll das denn funktionieren?
Das hängt immer etwas
von einem selbst ab.
Ich schaue schon
aufgrund der Vorlieben meiner Kinder
sehr viele Action-Filme.
Um mich auch etwas fortzubilden,
was da noch so auf uns zukommt.
Aber Fakt ist,
mein beruflicher Hintergrund
hindert mich nicht daran,
solche Filme auch zu genießen.
Ganz klar, ein absolutes Go.
Dann schauen wir jetzt genauer
auf "Cobra Kai".
Dafür haben wir uns
mit jemandem zusammengetan,
nämlich mit der Schauspielern
Mai Duong Kieu.
Die kennt ihr wahrscheinlich
aus "Bad Banks".
Und eure Eltern kennen sie vielleicht
aus "In aller Freundschaft" im MDR.
Dort spielt sie eine Ärztin.
Aber sie ist auch
seit ihrer Kindheit Kampfsportlerin.
Darum hat sie für uns die heftigsten
Szenen aus "Cobra Kai" rausgesucht.
Hi, Jack, lass uns zuerst in einen
Action-Film Klassiker schauen.
Und zwar: "Durchs Fenster fliegen".
Das passiert z.B., als die beiden
Karate-Dojos Miyagi-Do
und Eagle Fang
gegen Cobra Kai antreten.
Hier sehen wir, wie Bert zu Beginn
durchs Fenster geschmissen wird.
Er fliegt nicht nur durchs Glas,
sondern nimmt den ganzen Rahmen mit.
Kurz darauf wird er hochgezogen
und in den Gruppenkampf involviert,
als wäre nichts gewesen.
No mercy!
Ich habe das schon erlebt
mit einer kleinen Schnittverletzung.
Wenn ich mir die Szene angucke,
denke ich, okay, das tut mies weh.
Danke, Mai.
Durch eine Scheibe zu fliegen,
stelle ich mir nicht so einfach vor.
Fensterglas ist ja heutzutage
mehrschichtig und ziemlich hart.
Kommen Leute ins Krankenhaus,
die durch eine Scheibe geflogen sind?
Durch eine Fensterscheibe,
eher selten.
Was wir häufiger haben,
sind die Scheiben in den Innentüren.
Mit der Sache
werden wir öfter mal konfrontiert.
So eine Küchentür.
- Eine Küchentür.
Aber Verletzungen,
wo jemand durch ein Fenster fiel,
geschmissen wurde oder flog,
sind relativ selten.
Das habe ich in meiner Praxis
noch nicht häufig erlebt.
Bei Verkehrsunfällen
kommt das schon vor,
dass Passanten oder Mitfahrer
aus dem Auto geschleudert werden.
Und dann durch
die Frontscheibe fliegen.
Dann kann es natürlich sein,
dass ein Rest von Glassplittern
im Körper selbst zu finden ist.
Die führen zu schweren Infektionen,
weil das verschmutztes Material ist.
Die werden dann kontrolliert
und unter ärztlicher Assistenz
und Kontrolle entfernt.
Keine Gnade, so ein Fenster.
Wie ist das jetzt, wir sehen bei Bert
kaum sichtbare Verletzungen.
Sie haben beschrieben, dass da
teils noch Scherben drinstecken.
Das Bild sieht ganz anders aus.
Es geht ja nicht um Schürfwunden.
Richtig, bei diesen Verletzungen
muss man erst mal gucken,
wo ist die Haupt-Kontaktfläche?
Wo kommt der Körper mit dem Glas,
dem Glassplitter in Kontakt?
Ein klassisches Beispiel:
Ein Glassplitter
bohrt sich in die Brustwand
und verletzt die Lunge.
Da wird der Entsprechende
sicher nicht sofort aufstehen
und weiterkämpfen können.
Je nachdem, wie man aufkommt
auf dem Fußboden mit den Splittern,
können nicht nur schwere
Verletzungen an Organen eintreten,
sondern auch an den Extremitäten.
Gerade die Hände sind prädestiniert
dafür, sie sind nicht geschützt.
Da kann es zu Schnittverletzungen
kommen, auch an den Unterarmen,
mit Nerven- und Gefäßverletzungen.
Da können wir ja schon mal sagen:
So, wie wir es dort sehen,
ist es eher unrealistisch.
Was ich mir gedacht habe:
Es geht nicht nur
ums Glas in dieser Szene,
sondern Bert fliegt ja auch richtig.
Der wird 1-2 Meter geworfen,
über diesen Küchentisch drüber.
Also Stürze spielen auch eine Rolle
in der Szene.
Ja, der Sturz als solcher ist auch
immer eine Ursache für Verletzungen.
Gerade an Extremitäten,
Knochen, die schnell brechen können.
Aus 1-2 Metern Höhe zu stürzen,
wenn man da geschickt abrollt,
da hat man
kaum eine Verletzungsfolge.
Wenn man aber
aus dieser Höhe ungeschickt fällt,
je nachdem,
welches Alter man auch hat,
kann es zu schwerwiegenden
Verletzungen kommen.
Für uns ist jeder,
der aus 3 Metern fällt, jemand,
der in der Notaufnahme sofort
in den Schockraum gebracht wird.
Für diese Verletzungshöhe
steht ein Team bereit,
um ihn gesondert zu versorgen.
Der wird nicht
in die anderen Patienten eingereiht
und muss warten.
Wenn wir noch mal genauer
auf diese Szene schauen,
dann sehen wir da keine Brüche.
Das sind aber
trainierte Kampfsportler.
Wenn wir "Cobra Kai"
etwas zugute halten wollen,
ist das ein Work-Around?
Also sind die einfach so trainiert,
dass die sich dabei nichts brechen?
Das ist durchaus realistisch.
Durch die jahrelange Schule,
auch die Fallschule ...
Sportler lernen auch so zu fallen,
dass sie sich nicht verletzen.
Gerade in diesem Fall haben sie
bewusst diesen Sturz mitgestaltet,
sodass sie ohne Verletzungen
an den Extremitäten
oder dem Korpus enden.
Aber was wir in der Szene
noch gesehen haben:
Der Kopfaufprall
auf diesen harten Fußboden
wird vollkommen unterschätzt.
Aber gerade diese Verletzungen
können früher oder später
ausschlaggebend sein für
das gesamte Verhalten des Sportlers.
Also hier muss man sagen,
dass man da Obacht haben muss.
Schauen wir uns das genauer an.
Sprechen wir über Kopfverletzungen.
Ja, die Köpfe werden bei "Cobra Kai"
ziemlich oft
in Mitleidenschaft gezogen.
Ich habe 3 Beispiele ausgesucht.
Beim großen Kampf im Haus
der LaRussos in Staffel 3 sehen wir,
wie mit einem Gegenstand
geschlagen wird.
Da bekommt ein Kämpfer
eine Vase gegen den Kopf.
Das hat
keine schlimmen Auswirkungen.
Etwas heftiger
wird es in dieser Szene.
Da schleudert Johnny seinen Sohn
Robbie gegen einen Schrank.
Zwar aus Versehen,
aber mit sichtbaren Folgen.
Der knallt gegen die Ecke
und wird bewusstlos.
Shit.
Für mich als Kampfsportlerin
ist das am brutalsten,
aus der gleichen Szene:
Da schlägt Johnny seinem ehemaligen
Sensei Kreese 7-mal ins Gesicht.
Danach bleibt er kurz liegen,
aber rappelt sich dann wieder auf.
Also im Stand 7 Schläge
zu kassieren, ist fast unmöglich.
Das dann noch im Liegen
ohne Deckung?
Dass er dann noch aufsteht,
kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Da hilft auch
"auftragen und polieren" nicht mehr.
Das sieht schon heftig aus.
Was hält denn
ein menschlicher Schädelknochen aus?
Der hält sehr viel aus.
Deswegen ist er auch so konstruiert.
Er hält also die Gewalt auf,
die auf ihn einwirkt,
um das Gehirn zu schützen.
Die Verletzungen, die wir sehen,
sowohl von vorn als auch von hinten,
sind schon Verletzungen
mit einem hohen Potential
für eine Verletzung des Gehirns.
Aber die Schädelkalotte,
also dort, wo der Hirnschädel ist,
die bleiben meist bei solchen
jungen Leuten auch intakt,
wenn der Knochen
auch noch intakt und gesund ist.
Also es ist gar nicht
so unrealistisch,
dass die gar keine sichtbaren
Verletzungen nach sich ziehen?
Wie ist das
bei den 7 Schlägen ins Gesicht?
Mir geht es wie Mai,
das tut schon beim Zuschauen weh.
Ich habe zum Glück noch keinen Schlag
ins Gesicht bekommen.
Aber ich kann mir vorstellen, das ist
alles etwas fragiler hier vorn.
Die Verletzungen, die über den
Gesichtsschädel abgefangen werden,
führen zwar zu keiner wesentlichen
Verletzung des Hirns.
Aber sie können zu Verletzungen
im Gesichtsschädel führen.
Häufig sind das die klassischen
Unterkiefer-Frakturen,
die schon bei einfachen "Schlägen"
durchaus auftreten können.
Bis hin zu Oberkiefer-Frakturen
mit Beteiligung der Augen.
Die Patienten,
oder in diesem Fall die Sportler,
können dann
nicht mehr richtig fokussieren.
Die Augenmuskeln,
die hinter den Augen liegen,
klemmen ein in diesen Bruchstücken.
Und Sie sehen Doppelbilder.
Das sind alles Verletzungen,
in denen einfache Schläge
ins Gesicht enden können.
Die sehen wir täglich auch
in der Notaufnahme.
Also da würde ich sagen,
Kreese ist in der Szene
noch glimpflich davongekommen.
Zumindest,
was die äußeren Verletzungen angeht.
Sie hatten ja schon über innere,
also Hirnverletzungen gesprochen.
Da ist mir auch etwas aufgefallen,
nämlich die Bewusstlosigkeit.
Also der eine Typ
wird mit der Vase geschlagen
und liegt dann erst mal da.
Der andere fällt gegen einen Schrank
und wird bewusstlos.
Aber bei Kreese ist nichts,
und der bekommt ja 7 Schläge frontal.
Welche verschiedenen Stufen
gibt es da?
Ab wann wird man bewusstlos?
Und was heißt das eigentlich?
Durch die mechanische Gewalt
fährt das Gehirn runter,
wie ein Computer.
Der Gesichtsschädel
kann die Schläge puffern,
dass das Gehirn nicht sofort
und dominant verletzt wird.
Die Schläge werden von der Seite
oder über den Hinterkopf
auf das Hirn abgetragen.
Je nachdem
wo die Kraft eingeleitet wird,
gibt es im Gehirn
entsprechende Anprallzonen.
Die führen dazu,
dass das Gehirn in der Region
geschädigt wird.
Die kann man manchmal
nicht nachweisen.
Das Gehirn befindet sich
in der Hirnflüssigkeit.
Schlägt es mit der Gegenseite
auf die gegenüberliegende Hirnseite,
wird auch die Gegenseite verletzt.
D.h., wir haben nicht nur
eine lokale Verletzung,
sondern auch auf der Gegenseite.
Und die muss man auch mit sehen.
Das Hirn hat eine massive Verletzung
durch den Aufschlag erhalten.
Je schwerer die Verletzung ist,
je stärker der Schlag
ausgeführt worden ist,
fällt das Gehirn auch aus.
So ist die kurze Bewusstlosigkeit
die bessere Verletzung.
Die Patienten
stehen zwar nach 1-2 s wieder auf,
sind durch den Schlag
aber gekennzeichnet.
Sie haben Koordinationsstörungen,
Sehstörungen, Kopfschmerzen.
Sie haben Schwindelattacken,
stürzen erneut wieder.
Also einfach aufstehen
und weiterkämpfen:
unwahrscheinlich
und unrealistisch.
Je länger die Bewusstlosigkeit ist,
desto wahrscheinlicher
ist die Gehirnverletzung.
Mit massiven Schädigungen:
Blutungen,
Verletzungen von Hirnarealen.
Die können
zu bleibenden Schäden führen.
Faustregel hier:
je länger, um so schlimmer.
Und aufstehen und weiterkämpfen:
unwahrscheinlich.
Dann fassen wir die Szenen zusammen:
Das mit der Vase und dem Schrank
ist nicht unrealistisch.
Also, dass die Leute
bewusstlos werden.
Obwohl die Szene mit den Schlägen
ins Gesicht krass aussieht,
schützt das Gesicht
das Gehirn vor Bewusstlosigkeit.
Unrealistisch ist eher,
dass sie sofort aufstehen
und weiterkämpfen.
*Szenenausschnitt*
Jetzt sahen wir viel Brutalität,
und Szenen,
in denen die Menschen
schlimmer aussehen müssten,
als wir sie präsentiert bekommen.
Übersahen wir da etwas?
Vielleicht haben die Kämpfer
bei "Cobra Kai"
eine besondere Taktik,
um diese Verletzungen auszuhalten?
*spannende Musik*
In sich gehen, Kräfte sammeln
und sich mit Erinnerungen pushen.
Das passiert ständig bei "Cobra Kai".
Hier z.B. bei Samantha.
Ihr Vater spricht ihr
in Gedanken Mut zu.
Dadurch kommt sie wieder zu Kräften.
*Szenenausschnitt*
*dramatische Musik*
Noch deutlicher:
in dieser Szene.
Miguel ist in der Mangel von Kyler.
Er kassiert ordentlich Schläge.
Aber seine Erinnerungen und
Johnnys aufmunternde Worte im Kopf
sorgen für letzte,
mobilisierende Kräfte.
So befreit er sich
und greift wieder an.
*energetische Musik*
Auch ich kenne mentales Training.
Das nutze ich als Vorbereitung
für meine Drehs.
Das steigert meine Leistung vorher.
Aber wie es genau funktioniert
und wo die Grenzen sind,
das weiß Dr. Böhme.
Wie schafft es ein Körper,
in solchen Situationen
etwas auszublenden?
Man sah, dass es hier
keine Anfänger waren.
Das sind gestandene Profis.
Oder Sportler,
die es schon Jahre betreiben.
Da gehört eine mentale Vorbereitung
und Training dazu.
D.h., der innere Fokus
auf die entsprechenden Tätigkeiten,
auf den Sport.
Das muss man mit betrachten.
Dann kommt dazu, der Körper selbst
setzt Hormone frei.
Die lassen uns
Gefahrensituationen überstehen.
Was bedeutet das Hormon?
Adrenalin ist bekannt.
Wird als Stresshormon
in der Nebenniere produziert.
Und es setzt alles in Bewegung,
was der Körper
zum Überleben braucht.
D.h. unwichtige Organe
werden nicht richtig durchblutet.
Wie z.B. Bereiche des Darms
oder Bereiche der Extremitäten.
Die für den Körper
nicht wichtig sind,
um die Blutmenge
im Körper zu konzentrieren.
Hirn und Herz
sind die wichtigen Fokusorgane.
Auch wird ein bestimmter
Stoffwechsel in Gang gesetzt.
Der sorgt
für die Versorgung mit Glukose,
damit die Muskeln arbeiten können.
Der Sauerstoff wird
durch den steigenden Puls
besser in die Organe transportiert.
Wir haben eine erhöhte Atemfrequenz.
Alles das, was man
für die Unfallversorgung braucht,
um aus extremen Situationen
zu kommen.
Das regelt das Hormon.
Wir alle haben schon mal erlebt,
dass das durch die Adern schießt.
Man kann spüren,
wie das Adrenalin durchgeht.
Hab ihr das auch schon erlebt?
Wann hattet ihr mal
einen richtigen Adrenalinschub?
Schreibt mir das in die Kommentare.
*spricht englisch*
Sind solche Szenen auszuhalten,
wenn das Hormonlevel stimmt?
Wenn man Schläge abbekommt?
Ist das machbar?
Die Schmerzsensibilität
wird deutlich gesenkt.
Meist klagen Patienten
erst nach Stunden über Beschwerden,
die zuvor nicht evident waren.
Es ist realistisch,
dass man bestimmte Schmerzen
besser ertragen kann
als im Normalzustand.
Wenn man über den Rücken
oder darunter Kraft anwendet,
an den Rippen,
an der Milz oder den Nieren,
ist es unwahrscheinlich,
dass man keinen Schaden nimmt.
Ob man das in diesem Moment spürt,
und merkt, dass die Verletzung
zur Schädigung der Organe führt,
ist eine andere Frage.
Die Szenen
sind nicht unrealistisch.
Sinkt das Adrenalinlevel,
treten die Schmerzen
in den Vordergrund.
Sie zeigen an,
dass was kaputtgegangen ist.
Das Problem bei Adrenalin:
Es schützt zwar
lebenswichtige Organe.
Sobald aber das Level sinkt,
werden nicht-lebenswichtige Organe
an den Blutkreislauf angeschlossen.
Hat man eine Blutungsquelle
wie eine schwere Milz-,
Nieren- oder Leberverletzung,
kann es passieren,
dass man innerlich verblutet.
Es gibt auch Notfall-Szenarien,
da hält man Patienten in dem Level.
Man gibt ihm nicht mehr Volumen.
So kann man verhindern,
dass eine Blutung wieder aufbricht.
Wird aber das Stresshormon abgebaut,
können die Gefäße wieder aufgehen.
Die Blutung wird wieder stärker.
Kann man sagen, wie lange
ein Adrenalinschub anhält?
Kann man danach
diese Überschläge machen?
Der Schub hält noch recht lange an.
Bei einem muskulösen Sportler
ist diese Szene nicht unrealistisch.
Dann können
solche Überschläge möglich sein.
Aber, wie gesagt,
es ist nur eine Momentaufnahme.
Sobald das
in Normalität übergeht,
nach 20-30 min,
wenn man körperlich runterfährt,
können starke Schmerzen auftreten,
die man in der Szene nicht sieht.
Dennoch faszinierend,
was so möglich ist.
Man kann sagen,
dass einige Punkte der
Serie durchaus realistisch sind.
Es ist nicht alles fiktiv.
Nein, man muss das ganz klar sagen.
Die entsprechenden Verletzungsarten
und die Weise, wie man
den anderen verletzen möchte,
wurden medizinisch professionell
mit Background umgesetzt.
Alles, was an Schlägen
und Verletzungen ausgeteilt wurde
und beim Gegner angekommen ist,
wurde medizinisch von der Figur
so verkraftet, wie es üblich ist.
Ein paar Sachen
sind sicher überzogen.
Insgesamt ist es aber
eine realitätsnahe Serie.
Sie wird medizinisch
professionell beraten.
Es stecken viel Erfahrung
und Fachwissen dahinter.
Vielen Dank für die Erklärungen.
- Gerne.
Vielen Dank an Mai
für die Auswahl der Szenen.
Die Links
packe ich euch in die Infobox.
Wie hat euch
diese Folge gefallen?
Welche medizinischen Themen
interessieren euch?
Medizin haben wir
noch nicht so oft auf dem Kanal.
Schreibt uns Kommentare.
Vergesst nicht, den Kanal zu ...
- Abonnieren.
Und:
- Die Glocke zu drücken.
Wir sehen uns bald wieder.
Hallo, hier spricht
das lineare Fernsehen.
Ich habe neulich
das Internet für mich entdeckt.
Dabei habe ich
2 tolle Folgen gefunden.
Da gibt es was auf die Fresse.
"Mortal Kombat"
und "Kevin - Allein zu Haus".
Copyright MDR 2022